We know gravity is very weird in several ways.
It's also the force we understand the least
in some sense.
It's weird because it's incredibly weak.
For example, if you take the attractive force
— the gravitational force between an electron
and a proton in a hydrogen atom — it's something
like a billion billion billion billion times
weaker than the electromagnetic force that
holds the atom together.
So gravity's really incredibly weak, and it's
weak in a way that we don't understand.
The other odd feature of gravity is that unlike
the other forces we know about, which we can
understand at microscopic distances with quantum
mechanics, for gravity, our best theory comes
from Einstein's theory of general relativity.
And that explains gravity at very long distances.
But we still don't know how to actually take
Einstein's theory of relativity and combine
it with quantum mechanics to understand fundamental
gravitational interactions at very short distances.
So the third thing we actually know is that
over the past few decades, astrophysical observations
have told us that the vast majority of the
energy density, or the stuff that's actually
in the universe, consists of these mysterious
components that we call dark matter and dark
energy.
And we really don't know what these are, but
all we really know from these observations
is that they have to interact gravitationally.
So it really seems like gravity is at the
heart of some of these major unanswered questions
in physics.
A better understanding of gravity may be able
to help us start to answer some of these questions.